hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today is dr will
bolsoewitz dr b is a board-certified and
award-winning gastroenterologist he's an
author
and an authority on the cutting edge of
microbiome
science he's got a new book out it's
called fiber fueled
it's an instant new york times
bestseller and really a game-changing
must-read primer on everything you ever
wanted to know about gut health
today he joins me for what i think you
will agree is an incredible conversation
about
of course the microbiome why it's so
important it's relationship
to everything from your immune system to
your
hormonal health and even your emotional
well-being
he's quite the compelling authority and
i think you're going to find this
conversation incredibly informative
real quick if you enjoy this video and
my channel in general be sure to hit the
subscribe button
and with that i give you dr will
bolsowitz
[Music]
you look great the only thing that would
be better is if we were in the same room
but that's not possible i was hoping i
was holding out hope that we would make
this happen in person but
i couldn't wait any longer so nice to
nice to see you
through the computer screen man it's
great to see you too i wish i wish we
were together
in person i look forward to someday you
know hanging out
we'll do it we'll do it as soon you know
as soon as this lifts we'll get you out
into the studio and and
we'll go for round two because there's
no way that we can
explore everything that i want to talk
to you about
today we're only going to scratch the
surface but uh this is long overdue so
super excited i'm excited to see where
you're gonna take this i i have great
confidence in you as an interviewer
well the first thing i want to say is
that uh i spent
the month of uh december in australia
and i spent quite a bit of time with our
mutual friend simon hill
and every time i got together with him
he's like you got to meet dr b you got
you got to be he's the best and i know
that you've been on his podcast i think
five times at this point yeah so i went
back and listened to all of those
episodes
and wow there's a lot of there's so much
good information there so
like i said we're only going to scratch
the surface today and if people are left
wanting more which i know they will be
they can go and
and and check out simon's excellent
podcast plant proof
which is really that was that was kind
of a launch point for you
initially correct yeah i had uh
i had 10 000 followers going into that
podcast
and doubled that in a month and uh it
went viral i mean that's still the most
downloaded episode
that he's ever had i mean it's over 250
000 downloads for him
yeah that's great um so many things to
talk about i think
an interesting launch point uh launching
off point for this would be
to um kind of contextualize your work
with what's going on currently in this
pandemic era
that we're all navigating through and
what i've been thinking about lately and
i'm interested in your thoughts on
is how we square this
you know need to socially distance
and sanitize our environments
and kind of cloister ourselves from
other human beings and restrict our
exposure to
a variety of environments with this
paramount need to increase our
biodiversity not just
with the foods that we're eating but
with the
environments that we visit and the
people that we interact with like these
two things are at odds this importance
of biodiversity maximizing that
with this need to kind of over cleanse
everything at the moment yeah
i i feel like gut health has never been
as important as it is right now
there is a direct connection between
your gut microbiome and the strength of
your immune system
and for that reason it becomes
imperative that we take care and nurture
a healthy gut microbiome
and you know the the the thing that sort
of stands out to me
rich is yes like excessive cleanliness
um sterilizing our environment not
being allowed to socialize and connect
with other humans like all those things
are there
but to me the most powerful influence is
the stress the stress the stress is
um something that is affecting all of us
i mean it to
you know we are living through a moment
of collective
stress we're all forced to take this on
there's no avoiding it
and that actually has an impact
on our gut microbiome and it drives us
to this place
where we all sort of have different ways
that we cope and deal with that stress
and for many it's to turn to unhealthy
habits
and that includes unhealthy food and
in many cases alcohol and we're
compounding that stress
and we're actually compounding the harm
that it does to our gut microbiome
you know many people when we think about
gut health we talk about food and like
my book
discusses food in great detail the the
part of the book that i really wanted to
elaborate on and there just weren't
enough pages for me to go there
is the effect of trauma
the most challenging patients that i see
as a gastroenterologist
are the people who have been vic victims
of
physical emotional sexual psychological
trauma
and it changes them
and they don't realize the way that it
affects their gut
and typically when they get to me i'm
the fifth or sixth doctor
gastroenterologist that they've been to
they're looking for solutions related to
their gut microbiome or to their
or to their digestive issues and what i
discover
after getting to know them and building
that trust and that relationship
is that the the solution the path
is actually not through food
more so it's actually about healing that
trauma
that is eating at them on a subconscious
level
and all of us are dealing with trauma
right now
and i feel like collectively this is
affecting our gut microbiome
and it's at the worst possible time
there's a direct line between gut health
and our immune system 70
of our immune system lives in our gut
and when we have that
you know that emotional trauma that's
affecting our gut and then
we also compound that by consuming
alcohol
or by eating junk food we're putting
ourselves into a vulnerable place where
if we do
if we do get the virus we don't have
our defense system built up to protect
us
and that's the scary thing because
increasingly we're seeing studies rich
that are making connections between the
gut microbiome
and severe manifestations of covid19
where you know the doctors are all
asking the question who are these people
they get kova 19.
and you know one of the first things
that we discovered is it's the people
who are
that have diabetes and high blood
pressure and coronary artery disease and
are overweight
and then when you think about all of
those things that i just mentioned
diabetes heart disease
high blood pressure being overweight
they're all connected back to the
microbiome
yeah this idea that 70
of your immune system resides in the gut
is
profound and i want to dive into that a
little bit more deeply but
let's talk for a couple minutes about
the importance of
buttressing and maximizing optimizing
our immune systems right now i mean
there's a lot of talk about social
distancing and wearing masks and
all the precautions that we're all you
know embracing and undertaking to
protect ourselves
but i think in my opinion not enough
communication
and conversation around how to buttress
our immune system so that
if and when we come in contact with the
virus we're in the best
possible sort of situation in order to
combat it and
overcome it yeah i totally agree
i i feel like we have fixated on ways to
reduce
transmission of the virus which is a
good thing
you know you can you can affect um
the how contagious this virus is and
change the are not
with our with these sort of social you
know physical distancing measures or
wearing
face shields things of that variety but
that doesn't
that doesn't help the person who
contracts the virus
and a huge percentage of us ultimately
will
mm-hmm and so i i agree with you i think
that we need to
to speak more broadly about this and to
me
the the key in this conversation
is this connection between the gut
microbiome
and the immune system you can't separate
them
they're completely intertwined i mean i
want people to understand that if we if
you were to zoom in on a microscopic
level
what you would see is this single layer
of cells that we call the epithelial
layer that's so thin that
the naked eye can't pick it up and
this single layer of cells separates on
one side 38 trillion microbes your gut
your gut microbiome
and on the other side 70 percent of the
immune system and they're they're
communicating with each other they're in
constant conversation
and so as a result when things affect
the gut microbiome
they affect the immune system and vice
versa
you know when i was when i was
researching my book
i wanted to compile a list of the
immune mediated disease states that are
associated with alteration or damage to
the gut microbiome so basically we're
talking about allergic issues we're
talking about autoimmune issues we're
talking about inflammatory bowel
disease and as i started to
look for studies making this connection
i didn't find a study where the answer
was
no in terms of the connection between
the immune system and the gut
it either had not been studied or the
answer was yes
every single time that when you have
these
immune mediated disease states allergic
autoimmune type diseases
when they look at the gut microbiome
they always find that there's damage to
the gut microbiome in the setting of
these conditions
and so i feel like this is really quite
critically important and i'm happy by
the way to elaborate more on some of the
science
that makes these connections and shows
us how important it is to optimize the
immune system as opposed to just have a
bigger stronger immune system
so when you say that 70 of our immune
system resides in the gut
what exactly does that mean i'm trying
to imagine you know a locus of this or
what it looks like like what do you mean
specifically when you say that
well the
what we're referring to are the
g-a-l-t the galt which are the
um gut associated lymphoid tissues
and this is this comprises 70 of our
immune system and
you know the thing that's interesting is
this
the the gut our intestines
you know our colon which we refer to as
our bowels i mean it's literally the
deepest part of the human body
is actually the place where we interact
with the outside world
the most our skin is effectively a
barrier
it's a wall to keep things out our gut
is where we are actually interacting
with the things that we choose to put in
our mouth and swallow down
you know basically indicating that we
trusted enough to to include it
and our gut is where you know our body
is basically interacting with it it's
our place of most vulnerability
and as a result it's no it's really no
surprise that this is where
the immune system you know sets up shop
and performs the task of helping us to
identify like what is good
what is bad what can we leave alone what
should we be attacking
you know things of that variety and so
you know the immune system
isn't just um carelessly floating around
the body
you know it's it's intentional it's it's
intense it has a purpose
right this is the first line of defense
the the place where the outside world
interacts with the you know with your
body
it's outward facing which is you know
sort of people don't really understand
that or realize that but is
actually outside of ourselves and this
is the place where
the body decides what comes in and what
doesn't yeah this is this is the
gatekeeper and the immune system is a
critical part of that of that process in
terms of
protecting us from potential threats and
at the same time
you know basically standing down and
allowing the stuff that's good for us to
flow right through and come on in
so essentially to to ignore gut health
or to not have a optimally functioning
microbiome
is to put yourself at peril in terms of
your immune response
to covet or anything i i feel like this
connection
is critically important in the 21st
century period
i mean look at the explosion of of
immune mediated disease states you know
look at
celiac disease up 500 percent in the
last 50 years
look at inflammatory bowel disease
that's absolutely exploding
and you know there's there's conditions
rich that
when i was a kid literally didn't exist
that i'm diagnosing sometimes twice in
the same day
that are immune mediated you know things
like eosinophilic esophagitis
and so independent of kovid i feel like
recognizing this connection is really
critically important because the problem
is once you trip that wire once you
cross that line
you may find yourself with one of these
conditions that i don't
i don't believe that there's necessarily
a cure i think you can put yourself into
remission
but once you have one of these
conditions i think that you have it
and it's there well let's take a step
back and define our terms a little bit
i mean the microbiome is not a new
subject matter for this podcast but i
think it would be helpful to
kind of talk a little bit about what
we're talking about
and also to get a little bit of your
your background and what got you
interested in this field
so um the microbiome just to define some
of these terms
you know the microbiome is an expression
that we use to refer
to the the collective uh dna
that is provided by these microbes that
are a part of us you know we're
we're these big strong humans and um
we think of ourselves as these
autonomous creatures that are the
masters of our domain when in fact
we are covered from the top of our head
to the tip of our toes with these
invisible microbes you know
i i hold up my thumb i mean to the
listeners at home you can literally look
at your thumb right now
and there are as many microbes there as
there are people in the uk
you know so it's
absurd you know how many of them there
are and
i think you said in the book 39 trillion
micro organisms yeah 39 trillion
throughout the entire body
they're about 38 trillion of which are
actually in your gut
that's where they're focused and this
number is so hard to understand or
fathom
but you know to put into perspective you
take our galaxy the milky way and take
literally every single star that exists
in our galaxy
and you would need a hundred of our 100
milky ways 100 of our galaxy
to equal the number of microbes that are
a part of you
right now like not just you rich role
but like the listeners at home
yeah yeah you can't even wrap your head
around that so
it's impossible it's it's completely
absurd and you know they're not
they're not just there they're not
innocent bystanders
they're not along for the ride they're
not for the most part blood sucking
leeches that just take from us
we have had a relationship with these
microbes
going back all the way to the beginning
there never was a sterile human
you know the very first human going back
millions of years
they had a microbiome and we
rose and fell together co-evolution
you know if we survived they survived
and so we actually through the years
grew to trust them with certain things
within our body
and as a result we we basically
asked them like hey we need you to take
care of digestion for us
now we're incapable of keeping up with
the different varieties of plants that
exist across our entire planet we need
someone who can adapt quickly
more quickly than a human can so that's
what they do
and you know we have them connected to
our immune system
to our metabolism i'm sure we'll be
expanding on some of these ideas
to our hormones to to our mood our brain
you know the way it functions and even
to our genetic expression so
they're really critically important to
human health
some of the terms you know the original
question was let's define the vocabulary
so the microbiome is the collective pool
you know really we're referring to the
genetic profile
and the microbiota is the term that we
use for the actual microbes and i
probably during this podcast i'm
going to make the mistake of using these
terms interchangeably and i apologize
for that
how dare you um yeah it's quite common
um so the microbiota are the microbes
and um so those are those are sort of
the key terms and
you know what are we talking about here
we're talking about mostly bacteria
um you know good mostly good guys to be
honest with you
some bad guys e coli salmonella shigella
we've all heard of the scary ones but
actually most of them are good
and there to help us um we also have
yeast or fungi
and they're in competition with the mic
with the bacteria they're quite similar
in terms of what they like to eat
their energy source the archaea are my
personal favorite
archaea are these um
single cellular organisms they're not
bacteria they're not fungi
and they have been on the planet for
four billion
years which is fascinating to consider
because we've only had oxygen for 2.5
billion years
and they need to fire their publicist
and hire a new one because
it wasn't until your work that i even
had heard that term before we've all
heard of viruses
and fungi and bacteria single-celled
organisms etc but
i had never heard this word before so
elaborate a little bit more on on what
this is and why
why is this your favorite well it's my
favorite because they're so
they're so hardy they're so hearty and
resilient you know i mean they existed
for 1.5 billion years on
like a fire scorched earth that didn't
have oxygen
and you'll find them at the bottom of
the ocean inside of a rift vent like
miles deep you'll find them inside of a
volcano
and then you'll find them inside your
colon
i mean i personally think between those
three choices i guess i would choose the
colon if i had to
of those three residences but you know
they are
um they are a part of the balance as
much as the bacteria and the fungi
are and they actually are very deeply
involved in the production of
methane gas we call them methanogens so
now some people you know who suffer from
gas and bloating will hear this and
think oh gosh that means i need to get
rid of them
but actually they're a part of the
healthy balance in terms of processing
our food and don't necessarily just
unilaterally produce gas
they also protect us from heart disease
there are studies that suggest that if
we destroy them
that their destruction would actually
put us at even greater risk for
for coronary artery disease the number
one killer so
um they are um
they are a critical piece of the harmony
and balance that exists within this
ecosystem
that is the gut the gut microbiota and
you know just to sort of round things
out rich
there's also viruses viruses are not
alive
but they're actually part of the harmony
imbalance you know right now
the word virus is sort of almost
triggering in a way
but there are viruses that
don't mean us harm and they help us to
sort of keep things balanced within the
micro
the microbiome and that's a healthy part
of that
and and then finally some of us may have
parasites or protozoa
which exist and they in some cases can
be part of the healthy balance too so
you know the point is that there is this
complex
diversity of potentially a thousand or
more species
they live in harmony and balance some of
them are good guys some of them are bad
guys
um what we want is we want the good guys
to outweigh the bad guys
and you know when they're there they all
exist with a purpose
in the same way that you would find in
in any other ecosystem
throughout the world go to the amazon
rainforest
there's things in the amazon rainforest
that i don't particularly like but if we
destroy them to the point that they're
extinct we would leave a hole in the
ecosystem
yeah what's interesting is how um
everything you know in the macro is
is mirrored in the micro we can look at
the microbiome
and the principles that apply in terms
of trying to create a robust ecosystem
apply equally to the amazonian
rainforest and it's interesting to
understand that
there there's a kind of a beautiful
orchestrated harmony in all of that
that helps you to really get that
you know we're not separated from nature
we're very much
you know a part of it and can't be
extricated from it in any way and i
think
you know what's interesting about the
work that you do i mean just
contextualizing it there's been an
explosion of interest in the microbiome
and the number of studies that are
coming out right now i mean i i think
you quoted like you know there's like
thousands of them that are coming out
all the time but this is a relatively
new
field and you're dealing with so many
variables and trying to wrap your head
around the mechanisms that are at play
here and how they apply to health and
and disease so you know what got you
interested in this
and you know what does it look like for
you in terms of staying on top of
what is current versus because it seems
like
our knowledge base is progressing so
rapidly here
yeah this this is a um
this it is incredibly difficult
to study the specifics
of the microbiome because it could
change in 24 hours
and the tests that we have currently are
not perfect
but you know to answer your question for
me
i didn't go into medicine thinking that
i would be
a poop doctor i actually thought i was
gonna be a pediatrician to be honest
with you like i love kids
um to me the idea of like helping
teenage kids
to orient their life properly was really
exciting
so i actually thought i was going to be
an adolescent psychiatrist
and i got into medical school i went to
georgetown
and i was in my third year which is when
you rotate through the hospital
and i did my pediatrics rotation and it
just
unfortunately you know i mean i love
pediatricians and god bless them
but it just wasn't for me you know the
parents frankly were driving me insane
because they either were down your
throat
or they just didn't care about their kid
which was incredibly sad
and um i just couldn't deal with like
the
the polar nature of that so i
um what i loved about gastroenterology
is that i
i am an internist first and i get to use
my mind
to break down and dissect complex
problems
and i also get to use my hands on a
routine basis
about 50 of my time is done doing
endoscopy
and so so that's what attracted me and
the gut microbiome really wasn't on the
radar in 2006 when i graduated medical
school
i went to northwestern and things were
going really well for me professionally
i won the highest award in my residency
program
i i was the chief medical resident
and yet i was miserable you know i was
30 years old
i was 50 pounds overweight relative to
what i weighed in high school which was
hard to swallow because i think of
myself as an athlete i was a great
athlete in high school
i had high blood pressure i had a ton of
anxiety
i was basically fueled by either like
six coffees a day
or or red bull uh-huh
um i felt like i was 60
and i had low self-esteem which is
really weird to say because to
outsiders they would see what was
happening in my life professionally they
would think gosh
like everything was going well for you
and i needed something to change i was
desperate to find a solution
and the problem is that my medical
training as wonderful as it was
you know as as skilled as i became at
acute care
of the complex ill person who would roll
into the icu or the hospital
i didn't really have a solution for my
problem
overweight having low energy low
self-esteem and um
i tried to outwork it so you know
typical guy like a good type a yeah
i you know i was like the typical guy i
was like i can eat whatever i want if i
just work hard enough
right and so i was hitting the gym
six days a week um not exaggerating 30
to 45 minutes every time
of heavy weights and then jump on the
treadmill for five to 10k
or jump in the pool for 100 laps and
i could run a good 5 to 10k and i was
getting stronger
but i couldn't lose the gut and
so anyway i ended up meeting my
the person who's now my wife and
we would go on a date and she would you
know like i would be sitting there
ordering rib eyes and pork chops and
stuff and
we'd go on a date and she would ask the
waiter to do something that wasn't even
on the menu just like make me a plant
plate
have to have the chef put a bunch of
plants on a plate for me
and i was just like what the heck is
going on over there you know
i've never been around someone like this
before
and um but what i saw was that
she could eat as much as she wanted
without restriction she was cleaning her
plate she was loving her food she was
satisfied
very happy with the food and she had no
weight issue at all
complete control she looked amazing and
so for me it just opened up my mind like
maybe there's something to that maybe
this diet that i was raised on
and was okay when i was a teenager maybe
this is the problem
so did that uh inspire you to start
looking into
diet and nutrition a little bit more
deeply i mean where did where where did
you turn
i initially i i feel like for me i
remember
like literally the day that this
happened where
i usually would go to i mean i would
literally a couple times a week go to
hardee's i was in north carolina now
and i would go to hardee's trust me i
figured out whatever fast food joints
were nearby
wherever i lived that's the one thing i
was adaptable i know it well
and uh hardy's had this deal it was five
bucks and it's like
it's i mean it's disgusting to imagine
that you could get like 2 500 calories
for five dollars
like double cheeseburger chili cheese
dog
an apple pie and a soda and fries for
five bucks
so um one day i was like you know what
i'm just gonna
go home and make a smoothie and see what
happens
and i did that just bananas greens
berries
um i made it like it was like 35 ounces
and
i felt amazing i mean it like energized
me i felt so light i didn't have the
hangover where i have to lay on the
couch for a couple hours
i went to the gym an hour later smashed
an awesome workout
and that really motivated me and so i
started down this path of starting to
make healthy substitutions you know
nutrition is
nutrition is really just about leveling
up it's just about healthy substitutions
and so i went down this path and i and
then like
literally the fat started to melt off my
body
and these issues the anxiety started to
lift i started to feel
so much better my workouts were getting
better my recovery was better i wasn't
as sore
and so for me
i'm a man of science i
you know i i have such great respect for
the scientific process
and it wasn't enough to like
have this experience i needed to see
that there were actually studies to back
it up
so that sent me in this direction where
i started to look into it
and i opened up pubmed i thought there'd
be like five or ten studies
and i could not believe that there were
literally thousands
that i never heard about mm-hmm it just
wasn't it wasn't part of your
medical school curriculum at all
we're so busy learning about thousands
of medications and their side effects
we're so busy learning about these rare
disorders that we'll never diagnose in
our entire career
that we lose sight of the practical
information
that the routine person needs coming
through the door
and so yeah nutritional education
is completely devoid
in our traditional you know medical
education
and it just i just didn't have it so
when i opened up and saw these studies i
was shocked
and very quickly i found the connection
between nutrition
and the gut microbiome which was
starting to really take off
and it was really affecting my field as
a gastroenterologist
and that finding you know i just
started devouring these studies
and you know bringing them into the
clinic
because i'm taking care of these people
with irritable bowel crohn's disease
ulcerative colitis
and they you know they're real people
and they want to know
like doc i can't eat without pain what
am i supposed to eat i mean it's a basic
question
and most gi doctors don't have great
answers to that basic question
and i i needed to find something so i
spent you know basically
nights and weekends studying and
learning
um educating myself and implementing
this in my practice
and was shocked by the results i mean
amazing transformations in my patients
and it got to the point rich where you
know after
years of seeing these people who
like for me what i discovered
is that this is the root of the issue
and if we don't affect if we don't
address the root of the issue what are
we doing
just covering it up so
taking on the the the root cause of
these digestive issues
damage to the gut microbiome allowed me
to really
alter the health of my patients and get
them to a much better place
and so it got to the point where i was
like in 2016 i just felt compelled to
share the story
and i started my instagram account with
zero expectations
at all you know i'm gonna have to tell
you like when my wife and i were dating
it means my wife and i have been talking
about how surreal it is for me to be on
your show
no obviously because you're the dude
come on
i'm serious man back in 2014 you know
when my wife and i were dating we used
to do early when we were dating
we would call it the best weekends ever
and we would be like blasting all over
the southeast
having fun you know going to asheville
or
you know going to the beach in
charleston or whatever
and we would be in the car together on
the best weekends ever and we'd be
listening to rich world podcasts
and so it's really cool now here we are
six years later
and like i started this instagram in
2016 with zero expectations
if i had 500 followers i would have been
thrilled yeah but now you're a new york
times best-selling author
that even that is really weird the book
it debuted at like number six right
the book debuted number six launching a
book in the pandemic in the pandemic too
not an easy thing so i think it just
listen
the book is amazing um we're going to
get into the book in a little bit but
um the book basically provides you
with everything you need to know to
begin this journey for yourself
and it's written in a way that is
digestible for anybody you don't have to
be
a scientist to understand like you you
communicate in a very um
in a very practical way but i think it's
also an important book for
practitioners as well and i'm sure you
had that in mind when you were writing
it
and i think it it really is
important because as we speak about
preventative medicine it's all about
getting to the root cause
of what is creating all of these chronic
illnesses i mean when we talk about
chronic lifestyle disease people are
thinking about heart disease cancer
diabetes etc but you know
just to the side of that we also have
all of these autoimmune disorders
and all of these food allergies and
basically
all of this can be tracked back to the
health of our microbiome and
right now that microbiome is under
attack
constantly from environmental toxins
from processed foods from antibiotics
all of these things that we
inundate ourselves with that erode
our ability to maintain health
and effectively combat disease and so to
just sort of diagnose and prescribe with
the latest medication
is to remain blind to this whole
world that you're opening us up to about
how to
um prevent us from
getting into this situation to begin
with and it begins
you know when you're a baby and you know
having a vaginal birth and
making sure that you're uh you know
you're you're adequately
um breastfed and all of these things
that contribute to creating this robust
ecosystem that will ultimately thrive
and
maintain your health right
i i agree with you 100
and you know it's it's fascinating to
think about that connection
and how it starts you know between us
and these microbes early in life
because when a child is born this is the
closest thing i mean they're not sterile
but this is the closest they will ever
get
to being sterile and they are wide open
recruiting new members to their
microbiome come on in
i want you to be a part of it and you
know there's things that happen during
this period of time
from that point up to age two to three
where a child has a fully formed adult
size
gut microbiome like my son is three and
his microbiome is as big as dads
and this is a really critical period of
time because this is also when the
immune system is developing
and learning what is good and what is
bad
and when we disrupt the gut microbiome
and its normal development we also
potentially disrupt our immune system
and we see this you know it's as you
were alluding to rich
when you pass through the birth canal
that is mom
basically donating her gut microbiome
to this newborn child now it's quite
fascinating to think about that
at 36 weeks of pregnancy late in
pregnancy
see mom mom's vagina has a microbiome
and it's very different than the gut
microbiome but at 36 weeks of pregnancy
the vaginal microbiome starts to change
to more closely resemble mom's
gut microbiome so that the child passes
through the birth canal and receives
that
initial gift and then that child is born
and the perfect food
is potentially administered and by the
way let me say this that
i know we have a lot of parents who may
hear this and get concerns
um that their child was born by
c-section
both of my kids were born by c-section
you are you can
have a 100 perfectly healthy child that
was born by c-section or that was bottle
fed so
so don't you know be upset if you when
you hear this but
you know breast milk human breast milk
to me is like literally the perfect food
it has everything that we need to
nourish a newborn child
and what's fascinating to me is that the
human breast milk contains these things
called human milk oligosaccharides hmos
and these hmos literally have zero
nutritional value to the child not they
do
they do nothing for the child because
what hmos
are human milk oligosaccharides is they
are food
for the developing gut microbiome
they are prebiotics and they actually
help the right bacteria specifically
bifidobacteria
to grow and this also helps with
development of the new immune system
so when you disrupt this normal process
birth by birth by vaginal delivery
breast fed
frankly as long as possible when you
disrupt this
through cesarean section or through
bottle feeding or through antibiotics
early in life
you affect the developing microbiome you
also potentially develop
the effect the developing immune system
and this is the reason why we see these
children be
more likely not that they're all going
to but more likely to develop
immune mediated diseases like type 1
diabetes or like celiac disease or even
metabolic diseases
like childhood obesity you know this is
the reason why this occurs
is that this disruption of this normal
development process
can have downstream effects that can
carry forward through childhood and even
potentially into adulthood
in terms of of the protocols
that we should all be undertaking to you
know buttress our microbiome
you're not necessarily advising a very a
a specific
type of diet other than to say plant
diversity is king
like this is this is the vector of all
vectors for you
right so it's not about oh it's it's
vegan or i mean
it's a predominantly plant-based or
plant-based diet but
the diversity of plants is really what's
important
in terms of making sure that you're
doing everything you can
in the interest of your microbiome well
i think the critical piece to me
so you know the book is called fiber
fueled and that's that's because i feel
like
fiber has been this um
ignored superfood well it also needs a
new publicist
it desperately you are you are that
publicist you are
yes you're hired i'm the guy so
yeah no i'm here to i'm here to fight on
behalf of fiber and get it back on the
map and part of the conversation because
you know we've been ignoring it and part
of it is that we've been thinking about
it as this orange drink that grandma
stirs up so that she can poop
when in fact um it's incredible the
connection between fiber and our gut
microbiome
you know fiber doesn't just go in the
mouth and shoot out the other end
soluble fiber is a
specific sort of general category which
feeds the microbiome this is their
preferred food
and when we when we give this to them
they consume it they grow stronger our
microbes actually multiply grow
stronger and then they turn around
and they reward us and the way that they
reward us is by releasing short chain
fatty acids
and these short chain fatty acids have
healing effects
throughout the entire body so you know
we've been emphasizing a little bit the
immune system
short chain fatty acids optimize our
there are studies that we could talk
about if you want to connecting short
chain fatty acids
from in terms of protection from
respiratory viruses
they can have their effect in the lungs
on the immune system
short-term fatty acids reverse leaky gut
you know which is i mean dysbiosis that
is the root cause of these digestive
issues that i take care of on a daily
basis
they directly prevent colon cancer they
lower our cholesterol they prevent and
reverse insulin resistance which is type
2 diabetes
they travel throughout the entire body
having their healing effects we think
that they can actually reverse coronary
artery disease
we think that they can actually repair
the blood-brain barrier for people that
have brain fog
they actually travel into the brain
through the blood-brain barrier
and they have their effects they affect
our mood our memory
they affect um i mean believe it or not
we have
studies that suggest that they prevent
alzheimer's disease
these are incredibly powerful
and the way that you get them is through
the consumption of fiber in your diet
and here's the problem 97 of americans
are not getting an adequate amount
of fiber in their diet and that's
creating issues for us
everybody's worried about their protein
intake but
they don't give a second thought to
their fiber intake
97 of people are fiber deficient
i mean that's a shocking statistic you
know and that's well that's with the
bose standards i mean the expectation or
the standard that we're holding is 25
grams for women and 38 grams for men
and the the average american is
somewhere in the 15 to 18
gram range and you know you see the
problem exists
rich when we try to do academic studies
looking at fiber
and the way that we'll set the study up
is we'll say okay let's take the high
fiber consumers
in the united states and compare them to
the low fiber consumers
and next time you guys if you ever read
any of these studies i'm a nerd so i
read these studies
if you ever read one of these studies
take a look at the high fiber consumers
even the high fiber consumers are
deficient in fiber
wow
this tribe that lives in tanzania which
is
they're fascinating because they are
modern hunters and gatherers they don't
farm
they don't have organized agriculture
they live off the land
they they eat whatever is available yes
they eat some meat
and so but they they eat mostly plants
and these huds are consuming 100 grams
of fiber
per day and critical piece like rich let
me ask you a question i'm just curious
so you i know you eat a very healthy
diet
if you had to estimate in a given week
how many plants
do you think you have in your diet give
me a general idea
yeah i mean you know it's probably i
mean it's going to be higher than most
but it can't be more than
i mean 30 40. okay
and i would challenge the people
listening at home right now
like if you have to hit the pause button
take a minute and think about how many
plants you actually have in your in your
diet okay
so most americans are definitely less
than 30.
the majority are around 15 to 20.
and the hudza are consuming
600 varieties of plants in a given year
right like 600 600 because they live off
the land
there are literally 300 000 edible
plants on the planet the problem is that
we've narrowed it down to the point
where 75 of our diet is from three of
them
you know and we're ignoring this
diversity you know we put pressure
unfortunately on our farmers
where the farmer has no choice but to
opt for high-yield
breeds of crops and so they
we are we are narrowing down the bio
diversity within our diet through our
food systems
and so with the hudson do they so i mean
i
i presume that they have lower
incidences of all of these chronic
ailments as a result of this
biodiverse you know plant-forward diet
they have their challenges they don't
they don't live in the united states
with the healthcare system they don't
have access to a guy like me
right but when we actually look at their
microbiome
what we look at is the diversity of
species
okay so biodiversity is a really
important word these days
and the biodiversity within your gut
microbiome is a measure of health
the more species that you have
the more that your gut microbiome is
resistant
to sort of disturbances it has
all the different players that are
available you know they're not all the
same they have different roles
so when you have that diversity you have
all the pieces that you need no matter
what you throw at your gut
it's ready to step up and do the job and
so we want that biodiversity and when we
study the hudson
and we compare their biodiversity within
their gut microbiome to that of a person
that's
say in the uk we see that they have
30 percent more diversity than a person
in the uk
and you know i hate to break it to all
the americans who are listening right
now
but we're even worse they have 40 more
biodiversity
than we do and the connection that's
really important for people
understanding frankly
if there's only one thing that you take
away from this podcast listening to us
have this conversation today this is
what i want you guys to hear okay
the way that it works is this fiber is
not just fiber
there are millions if not billions of
types of fiber in nature
it's so incredibly complicated from a
chemistry perspective
that we're not even capable of creating
an estimate to how many types of fiber
there are
but every single plant has its own
unique types of fiber multiple different
types within that plant
every single plant is going to have
prebiotic fiber that feeds the
microbiome
this is their preferred food these
prebiotic fibers
and the key is that they are picky
eaters
they don't they're like us you know you
have different food preferences than i
do
even though i'm sure that many people
would label us as having the same diet
you eat differently than i do we have
our own preferences
and they do too they they have specific
food preferences
in terms of the different types of fiber
you know to put in perspective
take a black bean you give these
microbes a black bean
and there are certain specific species
that are going to multiply and thrive
and they are going to be stronger
and be more prepared to help you because
you just fed them they are energized
but the opposite is true you take that
black bean away you say
i'm going black bean free those same
microbes that were thriving because you
were feeding them
are starving right and they're not
getting what they need and so
you know rich this this
looking at the hudson and comparing it
to americans and seeing 40 percent more
biodiversity within their microbiome
that's interesting that's okay that's
that's cool
but to me i wouldn't write a book
based upon an idea and that is not
enough for me just to say with
confidence that the most important thing
for our gut microbiome
is the diversity of plant species i need
something more
and where you find it is the american
gut project
the american gut project is the largest
study to date
to take our diet and lifestyle and
connect it
to the biodiversity within our gut
microbiome it is actually an
international study even though it's
called the american gut project they
have
they have uh people who are
participating from over 40 countries
from around the around the world and
there is no study more positioned to
answer this question
what is the number one predictor of a
healthy gut microbiome and when they
analyzed this
it was clear-cut the number one
predictor of a healthy gut microbiome is
the diversity
of plants within your diet and so
when we set off this question you said
well you're not necessarily ascribing to
a specific diet well here's why
so i'm vegan you're vegan okay
but in this study diversity of plants
was more powerful
than being vegan because
if you are vegan and you eat the same 10
or 15 foods
every single day you are not feeding
your microbiome
and there are ulterior there are
alternative diets that you could do
where if you really focus on diversity
of plants within your diet
you're going to feed your microbiome and
do a better job so to me it's not about
the label that we apply it's about
understanding the concept
which is that it's critically important
to our to the health of our gut
microbiome that we incorporate as many
different varieties as possible and in
the american gut project
the line that they drew in the sand was
30 different plants per week
now that doesn't mean by the way that
there's a magic you know difference
between 30 and 29
or that 35 isn't better than 30.
the point is we want as much diversity
as possible
and that's the critical piece yeah
that's
super interesting and also so different
from the way that we're kind of wired
like as humans we want to know all right
tell me what
food is the best and i'll eat that or
you know just give me the list of the
five things that i need and i'll focus
on that
whereas you're saying look you got to
broaden the aperture here
and you got to be trying lots of
different things and you know
explore and it's not about like you need
to eat these three things it's about
basically um eating as many different
things as possible
and getting out of your comfort zone a
little bit and then i think
what you're saying essentially is that
the more that you're in the in the
practice of doing that
it's almost like an insurance policy
that you're taking out for
your gut health you're seeding your gut
with the
the biota um that that will then
ultimately be able to grow and thrive
the more that you're feeding it
those types of plants yeah no i totally
agree and just to kind of
just to kind of pick up where where you
left off
every single plant has its own unique
types of fiber
that's what i've been talking about for
the last few minutes
but there's so much more every single
plant has vitamins
minerals phytochemicals like
i don't know how much your listeners
have heard i'm sure they have about
phytochemicals
these are the unique chemicals that you
will find
in plant foods exclusive to plant foods
that's what phyto means
there's at least 8 000 of them very few
of them have we actually studied
an example of one is resveratrol so you
hear about resveratrol you know it's
resveratrol is capable of actually
changing the microbiome by itself
you know david sinclair in lifespan
talks about resveratrol
and its benefits for healthy aging and
this is just one example of one
phytochemical that you'll find in these
plants
and the other thing by the way that's
kind of interesting most people don't
realize this
the plants have a microbiome of their
own
every single plant so yeah you don't
really think about that
no you don't really think about that but
they're not sterile every single life
on this planet either has
a microbiome or is a part of the
microbiome
and depending on how you choose to zoom
out you could almost make the argument
that us humans are part of a larger
microbial in a way
right which is planetary health and the
way that it all functions
but these plants have their own
microbiome if you take an apple for
example because we have a study that
shows this
you know the apple has a microbiome that
is there
from the seat from like literally the
seed
through the flower and all the way
through to the fruit
and that microbiome is dynamically
evolving
and changing and helping this to
actually this transformational process
to occur
and the apple has literally over a
thousand species of microbes more than
us humans do
and potentially a hundred million
microbes and so when you eat an apple
when you eat an apple you're getting the
fiber
you're getting the phytochemicals of
which there are many you're getting the
vitamins and the minerals
and you're even getting the microbiome
that the apple contains right
wow and so each plant
has a story like that each plant
has something positive that it wants to
bring
to your health every single one wants to
bring something to your health
and if we over emphasize the foods
we can you know i could eat kale all day
and i'll have vitamin k dripping out of
my eyeballs
okay way more than my body needs but
i'll make myself deficient in other
things
because i'll be over emphasizing certain
things and i'll be
missing out on the other opportunities i
personally
would rather take 10 mediocre plants
and put that in my diet than one
superfood
i mean i honestly think that the
diversity because you play off of the
strengths
of all of them and when you have that
you get all of the amino acids
you get all the different types of fiber
to feed your microbiome
you get all the different phytochemicals
you just can't get it done with one plan
there's no perfect plan right
um diversification just like we need to
do
with our with our finances right it's
it's like it's like your retirement
yeah yeah exactly um shifting gears a
little bit here
let's talk about the relationship
between
the microbiome and and inflammation
which is sort of
you know at the root of so many of these
illnesses that we're seeing
absolutely so it you know many people
don't realize
the connection between inflammation
and dysbiosis which is the word that we
use to
to describe damage to the gut microbiome
so let me let me zoom out for a moment
and
do some new definitions okay so
you bios eubiosis eubiosis eu
refers to balance and harmony within the
microbiome
this is the you know what we see in the
hudson this is
a broad diverse microbiome all the
different species
yes there are good guys and they're bad
guys but guess what
the good guys outweigh the bad guys so
much that the bad guys can't do anything
they're they're incapable of really
hurting you all right that is ubiosis
and when we deviate from that place and
we lose that harmony and balance
we are moving into something where
there's a loss of species
potentially gaps or holes in the
microbiome that
we don't have the species to fill for us
because we're missing them
and the bad guys become more prominent
to the point that they could potentially
cause harm
when this happens we call this dysbiosis
okay it disposes
and dysbiosis is more than just a change
to the microbes
it starts to affect that epithelial
layer that we were talking about before
when we were describing the immune
system
and the microbes that single layer of
cells
and these cells are held together by
things that are like spot welds
we call them type junctions and if you
break
down those type junctions they pop open
and now you got a hole
that allows things to leak into the body
that are not supposed to be there the
scientists will call it increased
intestinal permeability
other people will call it leaky gut i
get it we're talking about the same
thing we're talking about dysbiosis
all right and when this occurs what's
leaking from the gut
into the body is a specific thing
called bacterial endotoxin bacterial
endotoxin also called lipopolysaccharide
actually activates the immune system
and this is inflammation in one word
bacterial endotoxin is inflammation that
is the word
and it can be on a number of different
levels
you could have smoldering low-grade
inflammation
and that's the type of inflammation that
leads us to developing cancer
or heart disease or alzheimer's okay
that again is driven by bacterial
endotoxin
and we can also have a surge or a spike
of bacterial endotoxin all at once
and that is sepsis sepsis is where you
have
over activation of the immune system
where the immune system actually becomes
your enemy
in the setting of an overwhelming
infection and this is particularly
relevant
when we discuss covet 19
because we all know that the people who
are the sickest with covenant 19
what ultimately is threatening their
life is respiratory failure
they develop something called acute
respiratory distress syndrome ards
and ards is not the virus
ards is the response of the immune
system
to the virus a
overactive immune system over
reacts to the virus basically goes
nuclear basically starts unloading all
its guns at once
the point that it basically breaks down
the lining of the lungs
and both lungs fill up with fluid and
that is not
you are incapable of sustaining life
unless you're on a respirator
in that setting and so so sepsis
you know where a person is critically
ill with an overwhelming infection
may get ards they drop their blood
pressure their heart rate goes up
they're not even conscious you know
they're they're
totally confused the pale
this is actually driven by excessive
amounts of bacterial endotoxin
excessive inflammation so and it could
be that full spectrum
wow i mean that's that's amazing to hear
that and so
in order to avoid that
you know what are the what are the what
are the things that we can do
that you haven't already mentioned to
make sure
that we have that gut lining intact and
we're not you know
basically creating that kind of
inflammation
so you know to me there's
my book focuses a lot on diet because
diet
is ultimately the most powerful driver
of the balance within our gut microbes
and we've talked already about diversity
of plants so we don't need to go there
again
but you know just keep in mind how
important this is where 97
of us are not even getting the minimum
daily amount of fiber
nor eating a diversity of plants so
that's a great opportunity
but you don't want to sabotage your own
health
and so we need to also take a look at
what are the things that are holding us
back or causing harm to the microbiome
and this is where i start thinking about
if we're going to talk on the dietary
side of things
look at the average american's diet 10
plants 60 processed food
30 animal products meat dairy and eggs
to go a little bit deeper on those
things processed food okay
so basically when we refine grains we
strip the fiber
not a good idea we're throwing out the
healthiest part
we're keeping the least healthy part
when we
build these processed foods that are
capable of sitting on the store shelf
in a box for like literally a year and
not changing
they are completely lifeless they have
no microbiome
and we have pumped them up with
chemicals
the food and drug administration has
approved
10 000 additives that are in our food
supply right now
i'm not trying to be a fear monger like
i sincerely don't have any intention of
being that
but i think that the issue is this when
you allow
in a very short period of time 10 000
new things into the food supply that
weren't a part of our great grandparents
life
and the level of expectation for study
is it does not require human testing
that's
at least 80 of them and the 20
that do have human testing it's oh um
you're still alive after a week right
yeah yeah all right
right so but but but rich what happens
when you eat that food for 30 years or
50 years
right and these foods you know people
need to understand that there is a there
is a
um cycle to our food there is a life
cycle to our food
where nature naturally will take it back
i mean look at a piece of meat
or look at a vegetable and at some point
it's going to decompose
and that process of decomposition is
stunned by microbes
you had your chance now it's past the
point of being human food
and the earth is taking it back this is
going to become soil for us
in the future right um particularly the
organic matter that you get from the
plants
this is compost we will create humic
substances
and so how do we disrupt that process
that natural process
get rid of the bacteria get rid of the
microbes prevent them from being a part
of it
you know where do you how how is it
possible to have cold cuts
that sit in the refrigerator for a year
unchanged and you take a couple slices
off every once in a while
you are reta you are keeping away the
bacteria that would rot the meat
and that's how it stays that way and so
what do you think happens when you drop
those
those food additives and those chemicals
that are designed to [ __ ] microbes
what do you think happens when you drop
it into 38 trillion living inside your
colon right
it's impossible to believe that that's
good for us
[Music]
and and then you know moving on to so
beyond processed foods moving on to
animal products you know in the united
states we eat 220 pounds of meat per
person per year
it's the english-speaking countries that
are eating the most meat i mean china is
up and coming brazil is up and coming
but
you know we are setting we are setting
the highest mark
in the united states and australia in
the uk
and there are people who are telling us
that we should double and triple down on
this idea
and it's unnatural
you know um the hudson are not eating
220 pounds of meat they're eating 100
grams of fiber per day because they're
not that efficient as hunters
right so let's get into that a little
bit we have the paleo diet the keto diet
now we're seeing the carnivore diet the
low carb
enthusiasts all of this are very animal
product
heavy animal product forward and you'll
hear from proponents of these dietary
protocols that
they are reducing their inflammation
that they are overcoming their food
allergies it's a very
restrictive protocol
but you know on the kind of front lines
of
the nutrition wars on twitter and etc
there does seem to be
you know a war for the hearts and minds
of of people as to which way is eating
best and
it would appear that these diets are are
are
in many ways winning that war because
people
like to hear that they can eat these
foods that they like so
what does the science say about these
protocols and
what does the impact of these types of
diets have on our gut microbiome
and i think that's where i would start
to be honest with you is to look at the
impact that these diets have in our gut
microbiome because that's what i'm here
to talk about and that's my area of
expertise but i also want to share some
of the layers of evidence that exists
going beyond the gut because to me
you can't prove anything with just one
study
you know as a scientist what i want to
know is i want to know the full
complete information and then i want to
see what the general like where are
things pointing for us
and i want to see all the layers if all
the layers are pointing in one direction
then we have we have scientific power
and so when it comes to the gut
microbiome
one of my favorite studies right there
with the american gut project
is a study from 2014 that frankly for me
was a big was a game changer
in my quest to change my diet you know
up to this point i was just kind of
leveling up
making some small changes but when i saw
this study
it really made me say you know i
just don't think there's any role for
animal products at all
when it comes to the gut microbiome so
let me tell you about the study
it's the authors were lawrence david
who's at duke and peter turnbull who's
at university of california san
francisco
it was published in nature the top
medical journal in the world
and effectively what they did is they
took a group of people
and you know let me say this like
they're not a part this was not done as
part of the diet wars
all right these are extremely high level
microbiome researchers
who were trying to prove in humans
what we have seen in animals
for years but had never to this point
proven that this was possible in a human
being
okay so now we accept some of these
things as as true but this was 2014.
they took a group of people they put
them on five days
of a completely plant-based diet
and then those same people would cycle
over to
five days of a completely animal based
diet
or vice versa some people started on the
animal-based diet first
but they wanted to see what's the effect
on the microbiome so they measured the
microbiome every single day
and what they saw in both cases was that
in less than 24 hours
you can actually change your gut
microbiome
your dietary changes that you've made
like what what you had for lunch today
is already changing your gut microbiome
and the reason why is because
it is evolving so quickly
in a way that's hard for us to fathom
every 20 minutes
there is a new generation of microbes
in one day in one day you have
at least 50 new generations of microbes
that have evolved that's like
in one day they're doing human evolution
that would take us all the way back to
the pyramids yeah
wow and so they're they're changing
dynamically very quickly
and um so what they saw was when people
were on five days of a completely
plant-based diet
your gut adapts to what you are eating
and when you're on a plant-based diet
you generate microbes that are
really good at breaking down fiber
and as a result you have what are
categorically described as
anti-inflammatory microbes that are
capable of producing
these short chain fatty acids that i was
heralding earlier
in our conversation okay so basically
you eat the fiber you get more microbes
and they want to reward you
with short chain fatty acids so you get
more of those
the alternative with the animal-based
diet
to me when i saw this in 2014 i found it
disturbing
what i was reading in literally five
days
you are seeing number one the
disappearance and reduction of those
microbes that are anti-inflammatory
you are seeing no surprise the loss of
short chain fatty acids if you don't eat
fiber which animal products have zero
fiber
if you don't consume fiber you don't get
the benefit of these short chain fatty
acids
and instead we saw different types of
bacteria
emerge bacteria that we would describe
in science as being biophilic what this
means
is they like bile bile from your liver
bile from your liver comes in response
to fat
it's meant to help you to digest and
absorb fat
in your diet the bile
actually changes the microbiome when we
consume a high animal fat diet this bile
starts to change the microbiome
and what we see are the emergence of
these bacteria that thrive in that
environment
less of the anti-inflammatory and these
ones we describe as inflammatory
so for example one specific bacteria
that we saw emerging during this five
day period
is something called bilophylla
watsworthia
and biophilisworthia is known to produce
hydrogen and sulfide
which has been strongly connected this
particular bacteria
to the to the development of
inflammatory bowel disease
crohn's and ulcerative colitis we also
saw
more microbes that are really good at
taking the bile
and transforming it into what we call
secondary bile salts so like look
we all produce bile it's in the part of
who we are
but what we don't want is having
microbes that are going to take that
bile
and actually use it against us and turn
it into these secondary bile salts
which are carcinogens they have been
strongly
connected to the development of colon
cancer
the number two cause of cancer death in
the united states and it's no surprise
that colon cancer you know just like
kind of looking at some of the broader
evidence
colon cancer is connected to red meat
consumption
into processed meat consumption so
we see these changes but you know
perhaps the most uh alarming change was
in just five days they actually saw
antibiotic resistance
within the gut microbes in on this
animal-based diet
you say gosh what's the deal there is
that because the
the animal products are are antibiotic
laden themselves
exactly 80 of the antibiotics in the
united states are not administered to
humans
tons and tons and tons of antibiotics
are being
administered to the livestock as a part
of animal agriculture
and what this is showing is that it's
becoming a breeding ground for
antibiotic resistance
you know if this cobit 19 thing is scary
to you let me tell you what's way
scarier than coping 19
a world where antibiotics don't work
because that would be taking us back to
before we had penicillin and in 1900 the
top
five causes of death heart disease
wasn't in the top five
the top five causes of death were
infections and this is why people were
living only on average to be
about 50 years old yeah that's
that's a scary thing but i think we're
we're inevitably headed in that
direction if we don't course correct
with the extent to which people are
eating you know animals
that are so antibiotic laden it's it
seems
like a natural byproduct that we would
develop
resistance to that we're creating a
system for creating a system
that where it is like the definition of
short-term gain
and long-term loss because the animals
receive the antibiotic not because
they're sick
they receive it because the studies show
that they will gain 15
more weight which by the way
scientifically speaking that's because
you're destroying their microbiome
when you destroy a person's microbiome
they gain weight
so but you know the point from my
perspective is even if you go
okay well we're gonna we'll go
antibiotic-free then we'll we'll stop
this practice of giving eighty percent
of our you know
eighty percent of our antibiotics to the
cattle and will go antibiotic free
it does not change rich even if you go
grass fed free range
it does not change the biology
of these high saturated fat the high
saturated fat content
that you get from the animal products
that causes a disturbance and alteration
of the gut microbiome
which causes dysbiosis where does tmao
come into play with that
tmao which by the way was not studied in
the 2014
study that i mentioned because it wasn't
really on our radar
at that time tmao
just to define for your listeners in
case they haven't heard about this
tmao is produced by microbes
in our gut okay our microbes will
produce
tma when they come into contact
with carnitine carnitine that you find
in red meat or also in energy drinks
or choline which you will find in high
fat dairy eggs
and meat and also some plants
so when these microbes in our gut come
into contact with those things carnitine
and choline
they can potentially produce tma
which gets transformed into tmao by the
liver
and tmao is i mean honestly
very disturbing it has been connected
to the development of coronary artery
disease or number one killer
to stroke a top 10 killer to chronic
kidney disease
a top 10 killer okay
and so tmao what's fascinating about it
is that you can actually train your
microbiome and make it incapable
of producing it but the way that you do
that is the elimination of animal
products
they had a study where they looked at a
vegan
and this vegan in the name of science
agreed to eat steak
and when they fed a steak to this vegan
there was no tmao they were incapable of
producing it
when they fed that same steak to someone
who is an omnivore
they spiked their tmao levels 600
percent
now here's the issue your gut
in all cases whether it's for better or
for worse
your gut is adaptable and it will change
and so if you take a group of vegans and
you start giving them carnitine and
choline whether it be in supplement form
or they start consuming animal products
they'll start producing in about four
weeks they'll start producing tmao
so the gut will adapt and start to
produce it
and this is you know when we think
about when we think about the long-term
risks
of a animal product meat-heavy diet
the tmao is a biomarker illustrating for
us the connection between these foods
and some of our top killers heart
disease stroke
chronic kidney disease and it's no
coincidence that you will find these
same
foods in population-based studies
to also be connected to these same
outcomes
and this to me rich is why
so let me let me say this when i hear
people
give anecdotes that they healed their
autoimmune disease on one of these diets
i don't doubt you i don't think i don't
think you're making this up okay
i want to see more studies but here's
what i think about that
there are 10 000 food additives in our
processed foods
those processed foods for most americans
are more than
50 percent of their caloric intake
when you eliminate those processed foods
you potentially may heal your immune
system
that that by itself is a step in the
right direction
but the problem is that are you going to
pay the price
when you consume one of these diets over
20 30 40 years i'm concerned
that with the loss of diversity within
the diet
you are causing harm to your microbiome
and that may come very early in the
process
but in the long run i don't view these
diets as
promoting longevity or promoting health
span
you're not going to live longer because
you eat a 100
meat diet that's the issue
i'm worried about the risks of heart
disease stroke chronic kidney disease as
you age and it may shorten your life
expectancy
which by the way is what we see in
population-based studies when they study
a low-carb diet
it's a shortened life expectancy there's
a version of that argument
that gets thrown at plant-based people
that goes along the lines of the reason
you feel better on a plant-based diet or
a vegan diet
is by dint of removing the processed
foods and you will see
a spike and benefits in the short run
but it's ultimately nutrient deficient
and to perpetuate this way of eating
over time you will see diminishing
results and
potentially harm yourself
in the process how do you respond you
know
i'm sure you've seen that argument well
of course but it's it's an argument
that's being made when people are
shooting from the hip
and not actually looking scientifically
at what they're saying because when you
when they have studied
all of these different diets and all the
different varieties that exist out there
a a vegan plant-based diet i mean like
you know i i want to separate out that
you could be vegan and eat
a junk food vegan diet and that's not a
very healthy diet sure right
so but a plant a 100 whole food
plant-based diet
when they did an analysis of this
that was the most nutritionally complete
diet
and the the the deficiency that exists
is really b12 which is so
easy to supplement and you would argue
that omnivores should be supplementing
because when they've studied omnivores
about 40
of them are either deficient or
borderline deficient in b12 so they
should be taking the supplement too and
it's so
easy let's talk a little bit about um
the gut brain access because this is
fascinating stuff and i think it relates
back to
um one thing we touched on at the
beginning of this conversation
which is anxiety the anxiety and the
stress that's accompanying a lot of
people right now
and what goes hand in hand with that is
you know depression
our emotional state and you've done some
fascinating work and you talk about it
in your book this relationship between
the gut microbiome and our emotional
well-being
you can't separate the two
you can't separate the two you were your
brain's best friend
is your gut and it's really fascinating
to think about because we
you know in the hierarchy of organs we
kind of think of the brain as being at
the top
and i mean it is it's critical it's a
critical part of being a human
but brain health goes through
gut health you know if you have an
unhealthy gut it is going to affect your
brain
and if you have a healthy gut you have a
brain that is being optimized so here's
how this works
they this is a two-way street in terms
of communication they are talking to
each other right now i mean they are
literally
your brain and your gut are like two
teenage girls on the phone for six hours
straight like how do you talk to one
person for six hours on the phone
i have a 16 year old daughter so i know
well how that works
yeah yeah exactly so so anyway
they're talking to each other they're
talking to each other literally right
now
your brain has the ability to talk to
your gut through
your vagus nerve which is the
information superhighway between the two
through um through hormones that are
released from the pituitary gland
and even through your your sympathetic
and parasympathetic nervous system
so your brain has the ability to affect
your gut you know this is part of the
reason why
we sort of led off the conversation
talking a little bit about stress
and when the brain releases crf
crf has the ability to alter the balance
of the gut microbes
and induce dysbiosis stress by itself
can induce dysbiosis now
on the flip side the gut has a
number of ways that it will communicate
to the brain
what's happening downstairs and alter
brain function
it can talk again through the vagus
nerve
the gut also produces neurotransmitters
literally the gut produces over 30
neurotransmitters
which is fascinating because when i was
in medical school i didn't even realize
there were 30 neurotransmitters i
thought they were like 12.
90 of serotonin
so serotonin is the happy hormone
serotonin
affects our mood our focus our energy
levels our memory
if i want to alter a person's serotonin
balance
i can give them things like zoloft which
is sertraline
and that is a serotonin reuptake
inhibitor it will boost serotonin
all right and that's how i treat
depression or anxiety
but percent of serotonin is produced in
the gut
ninety percent yeah that's not i give
zoloft only
it's only affecting ten percent of the
serotonin in the brain and the rest of
it is affecting your gut
and you know the there are precursors to
serotonin and precursors to dopamine
and other neurotransmitters produced in
the gut
that are capable of crossing the blood
brain barrier and altering our mood
this is the reason why we have studies
that show that you can alter
anxiety and depression with diet alone
and that a plant-based diet is
beneficial
in many cases and so
so it's fascinating to consider these
connections but one of the other things
that people need to hear about
is that short chain fatty acids like
butyrate
acetate and proprionate which come from
the consumption of fiber
also have the ability to cross the
blood-brain barrier
and be and be effectively
ways that the gut is able to communicate
to the brain and alter brain function so
there's all these different ways that
the that they're in constant
communication and affecting each other
and it's
dynamically occurring literally right
now as we're sitting and talking to each
other
yeah you also talk in the book about the
impact
of the gut microbiome
on cravings right the signaling to your
brain
actually like we all think like oh i'm
craving this so my body must need it or
or something like that but it's it's
it's quite literally
your gut flora saying these are the kind
of foods we need to stay alive because
this is what
this is what's going on down here right
now and we need to keep this going so
you need to eat these foods
um and i think that's absolutely
fascinating and it goes to that point of
us being much more
micro sort of microorganism than human
we're super organism we're a super
organism we are
we are a human body that is
like we are carrying life within us
and they're a part of the story and yes
they are
completely capable of altering the
cravings that we have and it's important
because
it also means that if you change the
microbiome
you will change your cravings you will
change your taste buds
so to me the idea you know part of what
people don't believe that
people have a hard time believing that
but that's 100 percent true
it's 100 true so you know for me when i
was thinking about changing my diet what
stood in the way is
i my favorite foods i was going to have
to give up
you know i wasn't eating these foods
like just
aimlessly i mean i was eating what i
enjoyed
and so that's what scared me and what
was fascinating
was that as i made the change
the taste buds although it they lag a
little bit behind because you need to
change your microbiome they came along
for the ride
and i knew that something had changed
for me
because like it's kind of like this you
go on vacation right
you're away from your home for like
seven days or 14 days
and you come back and there's that one
meal that you can't wait to have
you're like i'm going to that place as
soon as i land and for me
back in the day it was always jersey
mike's going to get a sub
you know um and
i realized that things had changed when
i started coming back from trips
and being like i cannot wait to go to my
salad joint and also get a kombucha i
can't wait
right it's so weird like what the hell
happened to me man
what the hell how dare you um one of the
things that
that i hear a lot um and i'm sure you do
as well
are people that are saying i get it like
i want to go plant-based i've tried it
it didn't work for me
i got super gassy i had all these
digestive digestion issues it just
it doesn't work for me i understand it
works for you um
good luck but you know i'm going back to
my keto or paleo or whatever
it is so can you speak to um
the issue of gassiness that people
experience
the relationship to the microbiome and
this idea that
you know eating a plant-diverse diet
might work for some people but not
others
try to do a little myth busting here
yeah totally well i think this is
actually one of the i mean it's
potentially the most important chapter
in my book
which is chapter five how to find your
plant passion with a sensitive gut
because the people that come into my
practice on a daily basis that i take
care of
for a living these are people who are
suffering with food sensitivities
when you have a damaged gut you often
will have food sensitivities
it's not a coincidence that like when
you're sensitive to the food that you
eat
it's not just a coincidence it's
it's indicative of dysbiosis it's
indicative of damage to the gut
microbiome
and the the specific categories of foods
that people struggle with
are fiber and fodmaps
fodmaps are the fermentable parts of our
food that can be transformed into gas
now if you literally just heard that and
stopped right there
you would go whoa those things sound
horrible why do we why would we ever
want that
odd maps are incredibly healthy actually
they are prebiotic
they feed and nourish the healthy
bacteria inside of us
and when you think about fiber and
fodmaps what are the foods that are the
most
rich in fiber and fodmaps it's the exact
foods that are creating sensitivities
for people
beans are huge on fiber
contain galactans which are fodmaps
and contain resistant starches which are
also prebiotic but can be disruptive for
some people
whole grains again extremely rich on
fiber
also contain fructans
fructans are a fodmap that can be
disruptive
so what we've been hearing for the last
20 years
is that oh if you're sensitive to that
you are incapable of eating that food
and also by the way that is inflammation
that's what we've been told that is
inflammation right there
first of all it's not inflammation
there's no there's no evidence to
suggest that
what it is is it's sloppy digestion
it's sloppy digestion because you have a
damaged gut microbiome
you know i want i want people to
understand the way that this works on
a cellular level if we were to zoom in
on what is happening when your
microbes are digesting your food here's
what you find
there is this fiber which is
biochemically complex
and these microbes a team of them
multiple different types
go to work on this fiber and they break
it down and deconstruct it
and to do that they use enzymes called
glycoside hydrolases
now glycoside hydrolases we big
strong humans we don't have them
we only have 17 of them if we didn't
have a microbiome
we would be completely incapable of
processing fiber completely incapable
but we do have a microbiome we've always
had a microbiome
and our microbiome when they study this
may have sixty thousand
varieties of these enzymes sixty
thousand a single cellular organism
that you and i can't even see with the
naked eye may have hundreds
of these enzymes so when the fiber goes
down the track
it's untouched by the small intestine
because we lack these enzymes
and then it gets to the colon where all
the microbes live
and they go to work using their tools
which are these enzymes to break down
and deconstruct the fiber and ultimately
to release the short chain fatty acids
if you're missing
the microbes that you need to process
and digest that food you're going to
struggle
and that's what we see in the person who
has dysbiosis where there's a loss of
diversity there's less species
when you lose those species you may not
be they may not be represented in a way
necessary at that moment process and
digest your food but here's the key
the gut is trainable the gut adapts
that's the key the gut adapts and
whatever choice you make
the gut will change you know we talked
about the study from five days of
plant-based versus five days of animal
based
in less than 24 hours the gut had
changed
so i want people to think about the gut
like it's a muscle
all right a muscle can be strengthened
you do that through exercise it doesn't
just randomly happen it happens
because you specifically go to work with
that muscle
and you work it to a certain point and
then you stop
and then it becomes stronger and next
week you come back and you can do even
more
but when you're training a muscle if you
go to the gym and you haven't been
working out and you
and you grab 300 pounds you're going to
hurt yourself
the person who has not been consuming
beans and like
you know says what the hell and grabs
the four bean chili hey
like yolo we're going for it right
they're going to hurt because they
haven't been consuming beans
and their gut is not adapted to eating
that way
for the person who consumes these foods
and struggles with food sensitivity if
you reduce the amount of those
individual foods
if you moderated them and got it to a
level that your gut was actually capable
of doing
that's where you want to be because
that's when you're exercising your gut
and it will become adapted and better
the more that you feed your gut with
these foods
and over time you will get those enzymes
because your gut will adapt to what
you're doing and become
capable of everything that you want but
the key
rich is this if you if you take those
foods away
if you say i'm going to categorically
restrict these foods so like
hypothetically
beans and grains beans and grains are
gone boom
okay all of those microbes that were
thriving on beans
they are growing weaker by the day all
of those microbes that were thriving on
whole grains
they're grown weaker by the day you are
not strengthening your gut
by removing foods you're making it
weaker
and i see these people in my clinic
every day that
they eliminate food and if they're lucky
they get a couple weeks where they feel
better
and then it's back to the same problem
and it's a vicious cycle where they
actually get worse and worse with time
so with that person that comes into your
clinic to extend the gym
analogy you give them a light workout by
incorporating small amounts of these
important foods and then increasing the
dosage of them
over time so you're seeding the
microbiome with
the plants that are the prebiotics that
are going to lead to the
gut flora that's going to ultimately um
improve the health and the quality of of
the microbiome and make it capable of
digesting
these foods at a certain 100
100 but i would i i would just
tweak the way that i frame it rich to
say this
a person who has a normal healthy gut
okay
they can go to the gym and exercise the
person that i see
who has dysbiosis and they and they're
suffering with these digestive issues
this is not going to the gym this is
going to rehab
you know this is this is me with an
injured shoulder
and i'm not going to the gym to see if i
can lift 20 pounds overhead
i'm going to the physical therapist to
see if i can literally lift my arm
and i have to go through a process when
you're rehabbing
an injury you have to go through the
process
and you recognize that it's going to
hurt
it's not necessarily going to be fun but
you are restoring function to your body
right because your body is healthier
when you restore that function
right so if somebody's experiencing that
gas
like just keep keep going basically
you're going to get to a point where
your body's going to acclimate to this
keep going but what you want to do is
you want to make adjustments you want to
tweak how you're doing it
you may need to moderate if you identify
what food is causing trouble
and many people are good at this they'll
say oh it's it's garlic
garlic and onions or oh it's whole
grains or oh it's it's beans
if you identify the food you can
moderate the fiber and fodmap content
and reduce it down slightly
so that you're not putting such a burden
on your gut all at once
and that's and just take your time go
low and go slow
it's like the beastie boy song slow and
woe that is the tempo yeah yeah
does that also apply to food allergies i
would think that that might be
a different situation so food allergies
is activation of the immune system
and so it's it's a different concept but
actually
there there there is an approach which i
wouldn't
want people to read a book and do by
themselves at home but there is an
approach
with food allergies where conceptually
you can do the same thing but even on a
smaller level
where you reintroduce these foods
gradually over time and you can
you can actually accommodate the immune
system so that it stops activating
um let's bust a few more myths okay talk
to me about talk to me about
lectins a lot of people out there
terrified of lectins well first of all i
would encourage you if you're terrified
of lectins
to go to pubmed and search the word
wecten
and what you're going to find is that
probably more than 50 percent of the
studies
are celebrating and heralding the
benefits of lectins for the prevention
of cancer
lectins are are often anti-cancer
molecules
i don't know rich how you write a book
if you're being balanced
i don't know how you write a book and
forget to mention
this important fact that lectins can
actually protect us from cancer which is
the number two cause of
death in america you know borderline
infringing on number one
but when it comes to lectins i want
people to understand that you know
where people worry the most are it seems
to be in
in legumes and beans okay
if you don't cook your beans like you
eat a dry bean
it's got a lot of lectins and you could
actually hurt yourself
there was a incident that occurred in
japan it's one of the few
one of the few publications that showed
in humans that lectins truly can have
adverse effects
there was an incident in japan where
they told people to grind up
dry beans and then eat that powder
and a whole bunch of people got sick
because of the lectin content
right it was like health day or
something like that yeah
so and they also there was another
incident on health day
in a hospital of all places back in the
80s
where they served a bean dish
that was not properly cooked and people
got sick
but like that sickness was like they had
a bug for 24 hours then they were back
normal
there's no study saying that people are
dying of lectin consumption
not there's no human studies you know
people
i want people to understand the
hierarchy of evidence
any time that we do a test tube study or
an animal model study
we should always look to verify those
results in real humans
i find it interesting when you put in a
test tube some weird concentration of
lectins
and then mix it with human cells and you
go oh my gosh look what happens in this
test
tube all right i find that interesting
but what happens when a real person eats
beans
show me what happens when a real person
eats beans you know what happens they
live longer
with less heart disease and with less
cancer the longest lived populations on
the planet
in the five blue zones are the heaviest
consumers of lectin rich foods
legumes and whole grains the the lectins
are not something that we should live in
fear of i'm
i'll be honest i feel like we deserve
better than to be propping up or
creating these
these dietary monsters you know
to to um basically be demonizing our
food to the point that we are
actually giving people eating disorders
i kept actually seeing this in my clinic
people with full bone eating disorders
because they get so scared of certain
food and they end up on the super
restrictive diet
and then they and then they end up with
a disordered eating pattern
we deserve better than this i think that
the solution is to stop running away
from these food monsters that are
artificially created and instead we need
to start running towards the food that
actually nourishes and heals our body
and promotes a longer life with vitality
yeah there is a
there is a um quite a bit of
fear-mongering out there
um and and what's interesting about the
work that you do is that
it's not about reducing certain things
you're talking about what you're
building it like what you're at it's
very additive
like this whole diversification of your
diet is about
building new things into your diet as
opposed to focusing on what
we're removing i i feel like it's
um easily applicable but
conceptually extremely sound like from
my perspective
50 years from now this is still going to
be the best way to eat
to consume a broad variety of plants to
be as
predominantly plant-based as possible
you know and
i i wrote the book rich to meet people
where they are
so you know when you say well you're not
rigidly inherent to any particular diet
i want people to be 90 to 100
plant-based
that's what we find in the blue zones
that's what i think from a nutritional
perspective is the highest quality diet
and i do think that when people get to
be 90 plant-based they're going to feel
so good they're going to want to keep
going
but i also think that there's an
argument that goes beyond
nutrition and talks about the health of
our planet
and talks about you know the compassion
for these animals
and i think that those should be a part
of the conversation
even if they are not directly human
nutrition i think that kova 19 has
taught us that when we abuse this planet
we may abuse these animals i kind of
feel like it's going to fight back
it's beautifully put and that just
speaks to the inner relationship
of everything you can't talk about the
microbiome without
referencing the macrobiome the health of
our gut is related to the health of the
planet
and vice versa the soil health connects
to human health
you know the health of our soil which is
the source of our nutrients
is critically important to human
populations moving forward
i have children and i am scared of what
this planet looks like a hundred years
from now when you consider what it looks
like today
compared to 1920. and
the reality is that we need to just look
at population right now we have 7
billion people in 2050
we will have 10 billion people consider
that in 1900 there were only 2 billion
people
consider that in 1800 there was only one
billion
people we have we're going to have 10
times the population in 250
years and that's putting a strain on the
environment
on our planet on a strain on these
animals
biodiversity is the word it's critical
to our gut health
it's critical to planetary health and it
needs to be upheld
um i would say that that's a great place
to end it but i'm not going to let you i
know you got to go in a few minutes here
but i'm not going to let you go
until we talk about fecal transplants
which is like my favorite subject
oh man how much time we got i know we
can keep it brief because
you have to actually go like perform a
procedure right in a few minutes here
but i'm still a practicing doctor yes i
had um
our mutual friend robin shutkin on the
podcast a while back
um but she she uh
regaled me with with fantasies of the
future
in which there will be salons that
people will go into
and get their very bespoke fecal
transplants to
buttress our our our microbiome and i
think the science here
is is truly phenomenal you talk a lot
about it in the book and
we'll close with the book but the idea
that um the adaptability of of
the microbiome is so dynamic that you
could
insert the biota the fecal biota of
another human being into a different
human being
and see tremendous changes in that
person's health and well-being as a
result
it's true it really is
related to restoring
harmony and balance moving away from
dysbiosis and back to ubiosis
and having the genetic profile that we
need
which is potentially missing and that's
because 99.5
of our genetics come from our microbiome
we are in terms of our genetic code only
0.5
human you know rich you and i are 99.9
the same in terms of our human genetics
that close
and i'm not saying that our microbiome
makes you look the way that you do
that's your human genetics
but our microbiome may be radically
different and it's certainly not the
same
each one of us has a completely unique
gut microbiome
fecal transplant really
came to become a necessity
because of an epidemic infection called
clostridium
difficile we now call it clusteredioides
difficile c diff
this became an epidemic infection when i
was in medical school in the early 2000s
you would see this occasionally
typically it was elder elderly women
who were on clindamycin a specific
antibiotic and they were in the hospital
and they would get this infection you
would treat it with antibiotics and it
would go away
in less than 10 years it got to the
point where 30 000 people were dying
per year that's a ridiculous amount of
people
and we had antibiotic resistance around
2010 to the point that we would have
people perpetually on antibiotics
they were just constantly on them we
didn't have a solution
and in our most desperate of times most
dire of need
we turned to the gnarliest of places
poop
and this actually became the
healing grace of you know this is
21st century healthcare on the highest
level
is to use poop as medicine
and what we saw is this rip roaring
nasty
infection that rich i have had people um
i have seen people die from this
infection i've also had people have
their colon removed as a result of this
infection
this nasty infection if you take
a healthy person's microbiome and you
basically administer it you know i mean
painlessly during a colonoscopy like
they don't even realize you're doing it
you give them a new microbiome within
two days the infection is gone
almost 100 of the time i mean on an
amazing level
and really all you're doing rich is it
goes back to an earlier point
the good guys suppress the bad guys
so when you restore a healthy balance
and you get more good guys
in the game they will suppress this rip
roaring nasty infection
the c difficile as nasty as it sounds
just get more good guys in there and
they can suppress it
the future of fecal transplant is
exciting we have studies ongoing to look
at fecal transplants for everything from
acute issues all the way up to chronic
issues
including autoimmune issues the if
if you want me to venture a prediction
for your rich here's what i think
is going to happen i think that we're
going to discover
that fecal transplant is really good for
dealing with acute issues
so when i say acute like this infection
c diff that's an acute issue that's not
something that's going to chronically
affect you
and so if you can disrupt the
disturbance in the microbiome
by restoring a healthy balance you could
resolve the acute issue
that's why it's so so effective
in that particular setting the challenge
is the person who has a chronic issue
can you fix their chronic issue by
changing their microbiome could you take
a person with ms
change their microbiome with a fecal
transplant and move on
and get rid of the disease and
i don't mean to you know throw a wet
towel on the idea
but i don't think that this by itself is
going to be adequate
here's why we have a study rich that i
mentioned in chapter one of the book
looking at young men who had insulin
resistance
and they gave them a fecal transplant
and what they saw which was amazing
because they changed nothing else in
these young men they ate the same food
when they gave them the fecal transplant
their
peripheral insulin sensitivity improved
so basically you fixed the insulin
resistance issue
but the problem is that over the course
of about four weeks
this benefit it dwindled mm-hmm yeah
it's like water it's like watering a
plant one time
yeah and so the issue is if you don't
change their diet you give them these
bread you give them these brand new
microbes
you know and you you restore balance and
a healthy microbiome
but then they continue to live the same
way they continue to basically
have a lifestyle that disrupts the
microbiome they're gonna they're gonna
go back to what they were before
and so it takes about four weeks for
that to happen so now if you could do a
fecal transplant
new idea if you could do a fecal
transplant
and pair that with dietary intervention
where you change their diet you change
their lifestyle you give them the tools
to uphold
this new healthy gut microbiome
now that is an idea that may have some
legs
but it still requires the dietary
intervention which gets back to
what my book is all about fiberfields
which is that you can change your gut
microbiome you can transform it
with diet and lifestyle and so i think
that this is
exciting but you could start doing that
today
without getting the poop transplant
right and the way that you start doing
it today
is with the f goals right so just rifle
through these and i'm going to let you
go i promise
all right so the f goals it's like this
so you know yes earlier in the episode
you said look you know we've been taught
that we need these super foods
and i stepped in and i said oh no no no
no we didn't we need ten different
plants instead of that one superfood
okay here's the way i want you guys to
think about this
plant-based diversity is the king
that is the core philosophy
but you're not going to eat every single
plant the same amount
every single day okay so at the end of
the day what i want
is if the plants are our friends which
they are they they're trying to help us
be healthy
if the plants are our friends i want you
to have as many friends as possible
but why not make the superfoods your
best friends
right so like in in real life if i could
have rich role in simon hill as my best
friends i would do that
that's exactly what i would do and
that's what you need to do with your
diet
make the superfoods your best friends so
f goals
is my acronym to help you keep track
of the main things that you should have
in your diet if not every day at least a
couple times a week
f fruit and fermented
g greens and whole grains
o omega three super seeds so flax chia
hemp put all three of them in your
smoothie boom done
a aromatics really i'm talking about the
flavor foods garlic
onions shallots l
legumes like i said whole grains and
legumes i actually view those as
foundational foods for the microbiome
then finally s i i
i couldn't control myself on s i had so
many i wanted to add so here's what i
did
i got three i'm going to save the best
for last
shrooms okay technically not plants but
we're making them honorary plants for
this conversation
they do benefit the microbiome
seaweed really it's sea veg
it's an untapped into resource you want
to add diversity to diet i'm not talking
about making whole meals out of seaweed
i'm talking about a little snack
and it's got unique types of fiber and
unique nutrients which by the way
you know when people criticize the vegan
diet you can find
many of the nutrients that people bring
up in sea vegetables
and then finally my favorite out of all
of them this is my favorite
is sulforaphane it's the nerd in me to
me
mention a phytochemical yeah you gotta
do it
yeah we're gonna do two hours on that
alone if you want to i'll i'll come in
and we'll talk about it but basically
sulfurophane
is a phytochemical that you will find in
cruciferous veg
like broccoli cauliflower brussels
sprouts etc
and it is the most powerful
cancer crusher that i've come across it
basically impairs cancer through seven
different mechanisms
there are literally over 100 studies of
sulforaphane
and so what's cool about sulforaphane
is yes you will find it in these
cruciferous vegetables but there's one
place
there's one place where you will find it
above the rest which are broccoli
sprouts
broccoli sprouts contain up to a hundred
times more sulforaphane
than you will find in adult mature
broccoli so today for lunch
i had a miso soup bowl
and i threw a whole bunch of broccoli
sprouts in there
and they're delicious and they have the
sulfurophane which is nourishing my body
helping to protect me from the number
two cause of cancer death
number two cause of death which is
cancer so if you
tuned out for this entire podcast and
you just need one takeaway
from this whole thing it's broccoli
sprouts
they're magic um thank you so much i
know you gotta go i'm gonna let you go
uh really appreciate the work that
you're doing
um you're breaking new ground here and
you're helping a lot of people
with a lot of difficult problems that
they're having i have tons of friends
that have gut health issues
everything from you know leaky gut to
ulcerative colitis and i could
ask you a million more questions i got a
ton of notes here we didn't get that
you know we got to maybe five percent of
all the things that i wanted to talk to
you about so please come and visit me
uh when the pandemic lifts enough so
that we can
responsibly be in the same room together
in the meantime
everybody pick up fiberfield thank you
for sending me a copy you wrote a nice
like
thing here appreciate that uh support
your local booksellers
uh if you can online and uh or you can
get it on on amazon i'll put a link up
in the show notes to the book
um congrats on making the new york times
bestseller list it's it's
well earned and well deserved and i
think that this is all
very much just the beginning for you so
i'm excited to see
um where you take all of this advocacy
in the meantime
you can learn more about uh dr b at
the gut health md on instagram that's
the main place right
anywhere else um well
i i have a bunch of great resources at
my website
which is the plantfedgut.com and um
you know for example i feel like we're
living in this confusing time
in terms of knowing that you know you
hear me say that lectins are totally
fine and then you hear a different
doctor say lectins
are destroying our health right so
and people are kind of sick of this and
so i wanted to provide a solution
so i created a research guide and it's
meant to give people the basic
tools that they need to understand the
fundamentals of clinical research
and how to find truth within the noise
because the truth is the truth is out
there the truth exists
with all my training 16 years of
training you know masters of clinical
investigation
i know how to to sift through this stuff
and find the truth
but i want you guys to have basic tools
to know what to do so i created this
research guide
which also includes all the references
from my book
completely free for download on my
website i also have a kobit 19 guide i
have an active email list that people
seem to enjoy
and then the last thing i just want to
mention real quick i hope you don't mind
is that
i'm super excited um about this book i'm
super excited about the response
you know to me if you say to me will you
got a choice
you can be a new york times bestseller
and help no one
or you can help a [ __ ] ton of people and
not be a new york times bestseller i'll
hand you the new york times right now
all right i'll give it to you right now
and so i'm really excited about the
messages that i'm getting from people
who are feeling the benefits from this
book i want you guys to reach out to me
i also want you to know that i'm
creating additional resources
i have a course that i'm launching this
summer i've beta tested it twice
with amazing results with amazing
results in groups of people
and it's a seven week course basically
to take an even deeper dive into the
ideas that you find in my
book so that we can really unpack this
stuff
and effectively what it is rich is i
wish
like when people read this book i hope
they feel that they're hanging out with
me
and we're just having a great
conversation and
in building the course what i'm what i'm
constructing
is the seven week conversation
that i wish i could have with every
single one of my patients i want to
teach you
everything that you need to know to
transform your health and that's what
it's about
that's great man um we should also point
out that the book has a
in addition to being this incredible
primer you have a 28-day program here
too that you take that you could take
people through the second half of the
book essentially
28 day 28 day plan it's got basically 80
recipes
um it's got i mean and one of the things
i'm most proud of with this by the way
is with the plan is it is designed to
meet you where you are
okay so the reason why i didn't write
this book to be
hey you need to be vegan and if you're
not it's a bad choice
the reason i didn't write that way is
because i want to meet you where you are
i want to i want to get a trajectory
in your diet and your lifestyle that is
going to transform your health
i want to point you in the right
direction and then let's get the ball
rolling
and let's do it together and so every
single person who's doing this 28-day
plan
is going to have their own experience no
two people will do it the same
and i celebrate that and i want people
to use the plan as a tool to get the
compass pointing in the right direction
but also to be comfortable making the
adaptations necessary to make it your
own
and i really think it's going to get
people to a better place when they do it
hmm
great man all right well to be continued
be continued my friends yeah thank you
so much man really appreciate it
um good luck with everything man and
look forward to finally meeting you in
person at some point
110 all right cool forward to it peace
[Music]
you